you
go Morgan
good morning den Oscar Nobel kumite
harvest em out Nobel stressed before to
Tuscany sculpting Delos President Barack
Obama parens Extra Ordinary insults for
Turkey international diplomatic
throughout history the Nobel Peace Prize
has not just been used to honor specific
achievement it's also been used as a
means to give momentum to a set of
causes and that is why I will accept
this award as a call to action a call
for all nations to confront the common
challenges of the 21st century
President Obama had been in office for
less than one year when he was awarded
the Nobel Peace Prize as he had had such
a short amount of time to prove himself
the decision to grant him the prize
provoked strong reactions I think that
the prize should be awarded for
accomplishment you know for something
you've done not the possibility of doing
or something you're in the process of
doing which is shown change but but
concrete change not not a vision of
change just as it seems strange to give
a Peace Prize to someone for what they
might do it also seems strange to give a
prize summit for the way in which they
do it the thing you want to applaud is
what have you done many people have said
that this is premature is too early I
would say that it could be too late in
three years time there are so many
examples in history that we didn't use
the opportunity to do to do the right
thing at the right moment where
President Barack Obama can create less
fear less ignorance less violence and
more hope that's where I have a Nobel
Prize Plus even Obama's staff were
surprised by the news I was asleep
my phone rang and I thought my chief of
staff calling at 5:00 in the morning or
5:30 in the morning can only be a crisis
so I answered the phone and she says I'm
sorry to wake you up but I thought you'd
want to know that President Obama has
just been awarded the Nobel Peace Prize
I happen to just be watching TV that
morning as I was preparing to go to work
and I heard it announced and at first it
frankly was a surprise and I won't
repeat the expletive that I used at that
hour because I thought it was the
equivalent of a jacked up April Fool's
joke but then as I thought through and
said who else really embodies the
leadership the passion for peace and who
else has a plan and who else has the
influence to make that plan become a
reality
the peace committee praised Obama's
ability to capture the attention of the
world and his ambitious proposals which
offer hope for the future I've come here
to Cairo to seek a new beginning between
the United States and Muslims around the
world no one nation can or should try to
dominate another nation no world order
that elevates one nation or group of
people over another will succeed I state
clearly and with conviction America's
commitment to seek the peace and
security of a world without nuclear
weapons on my first day in office I
prohibited without exception or
equivocation the use of torture by the
United States of America
president Obama has outlined his vision
for a new world order
he chose Cairo in Egypt for a speech
redefining America's relationship with
Islam that's a lot more alaikum
so long as our relationship is defined
by our differences we will empower those
who sow hatred rather than peace those
who promote conflict rather than the
cooperation that can help all of our
people achieve justice and prosperity
and this cycle of suspicion and discord
must end I had the privilege of hosting
at my residence the about 30 ambassadors
from Arab and Muslim countries to watch
the President's speech it was incredibly
powerful and moving to be in their
presence and watch their reactions while
a speech is a moment the work is ongoing
and I do think it helped create a
climate of openness and we're working
everyday now to take advantage of that
open where the previous US
administration categorized its enemies
as countries on an axis of evil Obama
has chosen to offer dialogue to
countries that were formerly on that
list the biggest change is President
Obama is willing to talk to people he's
willing to talk to our historic enemies
he's willing to negotiate not from
position of weakness but as a position
where we're trying to find out how we
can move too forward how we can bring
about peace
change is what Americans voted for in
2008 a new phase to present their
country to the world it's a choice the
Norwegian Nobel Committee has endorsed
well I do hope that history will prove
that we were right that it was now we
had the opportunity to support both
Barrack Obama once vaccine and then to
strengthen international cooperation
multilateral organizations and
international diplomacy as the president
has said himself this is an award for
which he feels he must be challenged to
continue to to do more it is not a
reward for what has been achieved but
but for the potential of what may be
achieved and I think he welcomes it in
that spirit
you